Supreme Court is upholding our access to abortion pills,
and this is a huge win for all feminists across the nation.
Let's talk about it.
The Supreme Court decided that the plaintiffs lacked status
standing to sue to remove beforprestone off the market.
Beforprestone was approved by the FDA over 20 years ago,
and in 2,023 alone,
the pills
accounted for over 60% of the abortions that happened in the US. Safe,
it's effective,
and it is a vital part of expanding reproductive health here in the US,
where one in 3 women who are of reproductive age
don't even have access to abortions.
This means that abortion pills will remain
available in two of the largest pharmacy
chains in the US.
And additionally,
abortion pills will continue to be available to order by mail,
which is vital for many of the people who need it
in states where abortion pills have been banned.
It's a huge win for feminist across the nation.
But let us know what you think.
Leave a comment down below.